Bitte schön.
Schön guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Berkis. Ich bin zuständig als Fürzi.
Bevor wir uns aktuell in Bechwerden kommen, benötigen ich einige Personen,
schadaten wir heizen sie den.
Mein Name ist Christian Müller.
Christian Müller.
Wie alt sind Sie? Hemmüller? Wie alt sind Sie?
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 58 Jahre alt.
Was sind Sie gerne geboren?
Ich bin geboren.
Kein Moment. Ich muss mal kurz was aufmachen.
Ich bin geboren am 15. August 1966.
66. Wie groß sind Sie?
Und wie verlegen Sie zum Zeit?
Ich bin 1,80 Meter groß.
Und ich wiege aktuell ungefähr so 78 Kilogramm.
Danke für die Information Herr Müller. Was wird sie zu uns, was für Beschwerden haben Sie?
Ja also ich bin jetzt heute hier, weil ich seit ungefähr schon zwei Monaten immer müde bin,
aber in der letzten Zeit wird das mehr. Ich bin sehr müde, abhusten, vermehrt, den ich sich wegbekomme
und manchmal habe ich auch Fieber und Schwitze auch viel.
Seit zwei Monaten immer wieder Fieber oder ist das neu nicht?
Ja also immer wieder, das ist jetzt neu, seit ungefähr zwei Wochen, dass ich immer wieder Fieber bekomme,
aber diese Müdigkeit, diese Abgeschlagenheit, das habe ich schon sorgen.
Haben Sie das Fieber gemessen, Herr Müller?
Ich habe es nicht gemessen, nein.
Haben Sie auch Schütze, Trot oder Nachschweiß?
Also Schwitze vermehrt in der letzten Zeit, ja.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie auch Husten haben. Kommt beim Husten etwas raus?
Nein, der ist komplett trocken.
Haben Sie Schmerzen in Ihrem Körper?
Eigentlich nicht, ich habe nicht tief einatmen, wenn ich tief einatme, habe ich Schmerzen und Brust.
Aber Sie haben in Ruhe keine Schmerzen?
Nein.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden, zum Beispiel, ist Ihnen übel oder ist Ihnen schwinderlich?
Schwinderlich, habe ich manchmal, aber der ist jetzt nicht so ausgeprägt.
Haben Sie Herzrasen, Herzglocken bemerkt?
Nur wenn ich mich anstrenge.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Abbruch oder Stücke genommen, Herr Müller, und ihr wollt?
Also, irgendwie zugenommen habe ich nicht, ich habe ja abgenommen.
Wie viel Kilogramm haben Sie abgenommen?
Ungefähr 7 Kilo.
In SS 2 Monaten, oder?
Ja, ungefähr. Ich habe einfach weniger Appetit, viel Stress, und ich glaube, dass Sie daran sind.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasser, oder mit dem Stuhlrank?
Nein.
Sind Sie in letzter Zeit häufig Infektionskrankheiten bekommen?
Nicht aus Füßchen rein.
Infekt Anfälligkeit?
Anfälligkeit, ja.
Das bin ich aufgefallen, nein.
Sie haben Druck in den Hof, Fieber seit zwei Wochen.
Seit zwei Wochen, würden Sie sagen, ist das Fieber,
tagsüber auftreten oder in der Nacht, mehr nachts auftreten, dieses Fieber.
Ja, tagsüber würde ich sagen.
Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein.
Haben Sie eine Hautveränderung, Bemer?
Neben Fieber und Husten haben Sie noch etwas aufgefallen?
Ich habe ein bisschen Luftdruhd, wenn ich mich anstrengen.
Nur bei Belastung haben Sie Luftnot, oder?
Genau.
Sind Sie deswegen bei Ihrem Haushalt gewesen?
Ja, ich war ungefähr vor drei Wochen da.
Der hat mich dann krankgeschrieben, weil ich wahrscheinlich eine Bronchitis hatte.
Ich war dann eine Woche krankgeschrieben, aber das ist irgendwie nicht besser geworden.
Deswegen bin ich einfach weiter arbeiten gegangen.
Das ist gut.
Was für eine Medikamente haben Sie eigentlich genommen?
Ich habe mir nur ein Antibiotikum aufgeschrieben und was gegen Gliederschmerzen.
Haben Sie jetzt auch Gliederschmerzen oder Gelenkschmerzen?
Nein.
Haben Sie eine Corona-Selftest gemacht?
Hat jemand in Ihrer Umgebung Engen beschwerden, z. B. Pusten oder Mühde?
Ich habe es nicht gefragt.
Meine Frau hat nichts.
Meine Tochter hat auch nichts gehabt.
Meine kleine Tochter hat einen Fett gehabt, aber der war jetzt nicht so dramatisch.
Herr Müller, ich habe eine Frage zu Ihrer krankgeschichte Frage.
Leiden Sie unter chronische Erkrankungen, z. B. Superkrankheit, Blutdruckdruck?
Ich habe einen Diabetes, der mit einem Medikament behandelt wird.
Ich habe einen Blutdruck, der acht Jahre ungefähr.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen?
Ich nehme einmal Medformin ein.
Wie viele Medikamente haben Sie?
Morgen und abends 1000 Milliam.
Und ich nehme einmal Ramipril ein, morgens einmal.
Wie viele Medikamente haben Sie?
Fünf.
Haben Sie noch andere Krönchen erkrankt?
Nicht das Östernalm.
Sie nehmen Medformin und Ramipril.
Habt ihr von diesen Medikamenten gesehen?
Nehmen Sie noch andere Medikamente?
Eigentlich nicht.
Wurden Sie schon einmal ökologisch?
Ich wurde noch nie operiert.
Sind bei Ihnen irgendwelche Allergen oder Unverzwecktheitende bekannt?
Auch nicht.
Wie ist Ihr im Status?
Sind Sie geimpft?
Mein Hausaufsinn sagt, das war nicht so gut.
Und treiben Sie Sport oder bewegen Sie sich regelmäßig?
Ich bin jetzt nicht so sportlich, ich gehe regelmäßig spazieren.
Ich fahre Fahrrad, aber mehr auch nicht.
Herr Müller, ich möchte noch etwas wissen über Ihre Lebensgewohnheiten.
Rauchen Sie?
Ich habe aufgehört.
Wann haben Sie damit aufgehört?
Vor zwei Jahren.
Wie lange haben Sie da vorgehört?
Und wie viele Zigaretten haben Sie?
Ich habe viel geraucht.
30 Jahre, 32 Jahre.
Wie viele Zigaretten haben Sie am Tag geraucht?
Ich habe eine Packung gestimmt.
Ich glaube, ein bisschen mehr.
Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Gelegentlich, am Wochenende.
Was trinken Sie gerne?
Bier, Wein, das, was gerade da ist.
Routenmäßig muss ich fragen, ob Sie Kontakt mit Trocken haben?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Ich möchte einiges fragen, ob Ihre Familie,
sind bei Ihren Eltern irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen bekannt?
Beide haben auch Diabetes gehabt und beide haben Blutotor gehabt.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich bin Einzelkind.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Architekt.
Sind Sie beide dabei, Stress ausgesetzt?
Ja, schon.
Wie können Sie das ausgleichen?
Schwierig.
Ich versuche mich am Wochenende zu entspannen, aber das kann man auch nicht immer.
Wie ist Ihre Familie gestanden?
Ich bin verheiratet und wir haben eine Tochter.
Ist die Tochter gesund?
Ja, ist sie gesund.
Wie haben Sie die Becher geblieben?
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Haben Sie Schwierigungen in Ihrem Bein gemacht?
Nein.
Entschuldigung für die Geräusche,
die von meinem Nachbarn...
Ja, das ist so.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Schwierigungen in Ihrem Körper?
Achselhöhe oder Halsbereiche?
Gar nichts.
Ich habe keine Fragen mehr.
Haben Sie alles besprochen?
Nein, haben Sie eine Verdachtziagnose?
Ich bin beruhigend, und würde gerne wissen, was es sein könnte.
Es ist verständlich, dass Ihre Symptome Ihnen Sorgen bereiten.
Aber es war gut, dass wir uns gekommen sind.
Ich werde Sie jetzt noch körperlich untersuchen.
Dann nehmen wir noch Blutab.
Dann können wir einiges von dem Bild geben.
Dann können wir uns besprechen, was das Problem sein könnte.
Es ist etwas genau zu sagen.
Okay.
Dann nehmen Sie Platz im Wartezimmer.
Ich rufe Sie wieder zurück auf.
Gut, seitdem es sehr gut ist, 16 Minuten.
Haben Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Ich weiß, und ich habe die Frage gefragt.
Ja, ich habe eine Frage.
Hatten Sie in den letzten 2 Jahren mehr als 3 Monate gehüstet?
Noch mal, bitte.
Das ist jetzt neu.
Seit 2 Monaten habe ich noch mehr gehustet.
Okay, 2. Frage.
Könnten Sie sein, dass Sie mit einem HIV-Effekt sind?
Das denke ich nicht.
Gut, die Frage.
Danke.
Bei Belastung Luftnot bei Belastung Luftnot.
Bei Belastung Luftnot bei Belastung Taki Kardi.
Manchmal vertigo, schwindelig.
Müssen wir die Schwindeliggenau bescheiden, Herr Kollege?
Ja, ich finde es eher so, dass ich manchmal so schwanker bin.
Ich glaube, dass ich falle, wie auf einem Schiff.
Aber ich habe nur ein paar Sekunden gestartet und dann bin ich wieder weg.
Wenn ich gebaut bin, dann bin ich aufgerichtet.
Bei einem Tiefinspiration, wir patieren sich Burjimersen.
Ja, mit der linke Seite.
Beschreibung und Tag müssen wir fragen?
Ja, das denke ich schon.
Wenn ich tief durchatmen habe, ist es eine stechende Schmerz auf der linken Seite.
Geiler ungefähr 6 von 10 würde ich sagen.
Muss ich?
Ich werde mich nicht befürchten.
Ich habe noch nie so eine Beschreibung gehabt.
Ich werde mich nicht befürchten, wie viele Menschen ich bin, wie viele Menschen ich schlafen.
Einmal.
Ich habe nicht die Schlaf-Situation gefragt.
Ich schlafe ganz gut.
Ich denke, alle Fragen sind noch nicht getroffen.
Beide sind verstanden.
Wie viele Jahre alt warst du?
Die waren beide schon über 80 Jahre alt.
Wir sind zu kurz umgestorben.
Ich denke, alle Fragen sind getroffen.
Können wir als Erste Gezieble anfangen?
Ja.
Wie geht es dir, Abdullah?
Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Gerade habe ich einen neuen Patienten gesehen, den ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Welche Zeit dafür?
Es handelt sich um Herrn Christian Müller.
Er ist 58 Jahre alt, 1,80 m groß und 78 kg schwer.
Er stellte sich heute seit zwei Monaten bestehende Müdigkeit und trockenen Husten vor.
Er stellte sich vor, dass die Fieber vor zwei Wochen aufgetreten.
Der Patient hat seine Köpeltemperatur nicht gemessen.
Neben dem Fieber klagte der Patient über Nachschweiß und Schüttelfrost.
Nachschweiß oder Nachschweiß?
Nachschweiß, aber kein Schüttelfrost.
Okay.
Nachschweiß und Schüttelfrost.
Nein.
Er hat noch nie eine Beschwerden gehabt.
Vor drei Wochen, als er bei seinem Hausarzt war, er wurde mit Antibiotische Therapie behandelt.
Er hat noch nie eine Corona-Test selbst gemacht.
Er hat eine Gewüst- und Gewicht-Zunahme von etwa 7 kg in der Halbfond.
Gewolltung?
Gewolltung.
Und inapätenz?
Er hat noch nie eine Corona-Test selbst gemacht.
Er hat nur Progradienten.
Er hat 30 Jahre lang eine Packung Zigaretentäglich geraubt.
Er trinkt gelegentlich Bier oder Wein am Wochenende.
Eine Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Er hat in der Familie Anamnese erwähnt, dass sein Vater eine Diabetesmellitus-Typsüa
und arteriale Hypertonie gelitten hat.
Er hat über 80 Jahre verstorben.
Er hat keine Geschwister.
Er ist als Architektin tätig.
Er hat eine gesundere Tochter.
Was glauben Sie, was der Patient hat?
Aufgrund der Symptomatik denke ich an eine Brunschtis und atmische Pynomonie.
Als differenzialen Diagnosen kommen eine Lungenkarsinom in Betracht
aufgrund einer Gewusstabnahme.
Als erste Massistame würde ich den Patienten Körper untersuchen,
ob es eine Luftotentöne gibt oder nicht.
Ich auskultiere Herz und Lunge, ob es eine auffällige Herzgeräusche gibt oder nicht.
Ich werde eine Rassengeräusche bei einer Pynomonie abnehmen.
Ich werde eine Blutabnahme mit einer Blutbildentzündung,
gegebenenfalls eine CT-Thorax heranlassen.
Sie haben die Verdachtdiagnose einer Brunschtis gestellt oder atypsche Pynomonie?
Meinen Sie, das hält ungefähr zwei Monate lang?
Vielleicht, soweit ich weiß.
Atypsche Pynomone geht mit einer Brockenhausung einher.
Auch mit gewisses Verlust?
Gewisse Verlust spricht dagegen.
Sie haben die Verdachtdiagnose gut gemacht,
entweder eine Brunschtis oder eine Lungenkarsinom.
Was glauben Sie, was der Patient hat?
Wegen der Bezümbtomatik denke ich auf eine Schwierigstimpfeil,
eine Lungenkarsinom, um das zu erhärten,
werde ich weitere Diagnostemaßnahmen durchführen.
Jetzt kann ich nicht so viel sagen.
Ich möchte nur ein Röntgenbild machen oder eine CT-Thorax machen,
um zu schauen, ob das eine Verchätzung ist.
Vielleicht eine Bronkostoffie, je nach Befund.
Ob da ein Röntgenbild, eine neoplastische Verchätzung ist
muss man entscheiden, ob man das eventuell dann bronchoscopisch umkommt.
Ich finde es ganz okay.
Das ist fast alles gefragt worden.
Der Patient hat ja wahrscheinlich eine COPD,
haben Sie nicht gefragt, wissen wir nicht,
weil er hat 30 Jahre lang geraucht.
Er nimmt aber auch keine Inhalative ein oder so etwas in der Art.
Aber hätte man auch fragen können, ist bei Ihnen eine COPD bekannt,
dass Sie eine haushaltfraktionen Funktion machen lassen,
dass Sie fragen können.
Aber die gleichen Fragen, unsere Kollegen haben gefragt,
wer?
Früher hat unsere Kollegen diese Fragen gestarrt.
Okay, dann habe ich das nicht gehört.
Aber COPD wurde nicht erwähnt, oder?
Nein, nicht erwähnt, aber unsere Kollegen haben die gleichen Fragen.
Okay, alles gut.
Müssen wir die selten Frage stellen,
wurde bei Ihnen eine COPD Diagnose gespielt?
Der hat ja schon lange geraucht, 30 Jahre.
Ich hätte mindestens gefragt,
ist schon mal eine Lungenfunktion Diagnose gemacht worden.
Das hätte ich schon mal gefragt.
Ich hätte auch gefragt,
ob Sie eine Grundgebild bei Ihnen fragen können.
Wichtige Frage auch, warum haben Sie aufgehört zu rauchen?
Warum?
Zu teuer?
Oder hat der Arzt gesagt, Sie müssen aufhören?
Wissen wir nicht.
Und ich hätte noch eins gefragt,
haben Sie wegen dem Husten,
haben Sie Blut bemerkt, zum Beispiel,
kann man auch fragen, Hemoptysen,
kann man auch nachfragen.
Aber hat der Patient auch nicht erwähnt?
Herr Kollege, bei Ihnen gesprochen habe ich
eine Titel gelesen,
Verschleppte Bronschitis.
Ja.
Als Verschleppte werden Erkrankungen
bezeichnet, die nicht ausgehalten sind.
Ganz genau.
Eine Verschleppte Erkrankung sieht beispielsweise häufig
eine akute Bronschitis nach sich,
eine verschleppte Bronschitis,
kann wiederum Ursache für andere Atemwegserkrankungen,
wie zum Beispiel eine Lungenernsundung sein.
Ganz genau.
Diese Patientin kann sein?
Richtig, kann sein.
Aber nach Schweiß und Fieber
und Gewichtsverlust,
Deuten oder Schmier,
Deuten näher auf B10, würde ich sagen.
Aber kann auch sein, natürlich.
Aber welche Diagnose kann ich sagen?
Nicht für die B10,
aber für die Bronschitis.
Danke schön.
Bronschitis.
Habt Ihr Kollege noch andere Fragen?
Arsarske Schipre?
War eigentlich ein einfacher Fall, oder?
Ja.